this is what it might look like the car
of the future fast flashy and with some
very eye-catching curves dubbed the
Kozma Tron it's the work of Paul bacon
from Britain he decided to come up with
the car because conventional rides were
too boring
this this would be the kind of car that
I'd be driving in line 2013 and this
would be how the future would be but you
know you get here and it's it's very
disappointing because this isn't what
cars are like and probably for a good
reason but yeah I thought I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm just gonna make that happen
the cosmo tron takes its inspiration
from old sci-fi movies it's futuristic
the way the future was imagined back in
the 1950s and 60s the engine sticks up
through the bonnet like a rocket and the
driver sits under a bubble made of
plexiglass
I think the view of the future
from the viewpoint of the early 1960s in
the 1950s it's just a very optimistic
view of what the future would be like
what with you know the moon landings and
the space race and I tried to build the
car with that view of the future and
without maybe our view of the future
today the cosmo tron was put together in
paul Bacon's garden shed here in the
City of Leicester normally bacon toils
away he using spare parts to make
souped-up bicycles which he later rents
or sells right now he's working on a
lowrider a bike that's built close to
the ground my first world of my my dad
when I was when I was 12 I learned to
weld then and ever since then I've
realized that you know a bicycle can
easily be chopped around in something
wild in about the space of a day
so unlike the car that takes 18 months
you can you can get that big sort of
reaction on the street in about 12 hours
you know the space-age Kozma Tron gets
that big reaction when bacon takes it
out for a spin through downtown less up
every time he parks he's sure to draw a
crowd
it's the most amazing thing I've ever
seen it's come straight out of 1970s
scooby-doo isn't it Ruby isn't very much
like a scooby-doo car I've never seen
anything like it must have taken five
thousand hours to make that'd be quite
nice that was spinning it see what it
was like yeah it's a cool idea it's
different idea and retro is cool say but
with a modern twist see I like that idea
very much the technology in the Kozma
Tron also has a modern twist to it the
chassis of a BMW z3 from 1998 forms the
base
it took bacon 18 months and plenty of
fiberglass and recycled materials to
transform it into his dream machine I
wanted the whole BMW package so the
engine the gearbox the suspension and
I've not touched any of it it's just
pretty much how it came from the factory
but then I wanted the the flamboyant
design on top of that and yeah it just
provided you know the perfect base the
leftover parts will reuse - of course
for a custom made bicycle there was bits
left over from that one of the bits
being the space saver
tire so I cut the center out of it
mounted it on the back you know it says
it's good for 50 kilometers an hour so
I'm presuming it's all going to be okay
it's got two foot brakes it doesn't go
that fast highly impractical bike but
you know it looks cool
however the Kozma Tron is perfectly
roadworthy and boasts the top speed of
over 200 kilometers an hour now Paul
bacon just needs to find a buyer someone
who will appreciate the Kozma Tron's
unique appeal